نشاهد وبشكل مباشر الان
من العاصمه الفرنسيه حيث
الاشتباكات بين قوات الشرطه
والمحتجين بالطبع الشرطه شرطه مكافحه
الشغب تستخدم قناه بالمسيله للدموع المياه
وسجلت بعض الحالات
سنتابع هذا الموضوع بعد قليل مع مراسلنا
في باريس فادي الدهوك ولكن التظاهرات كما
ذكرنا لا تقتصر فقط على باريس على مدن
فرنسيه اخرى ابرزها كنوز
وغيرها من
المدن
بالطبع يعني استغل المتظاهرون يوم عيد
العمال في الاول مما يو
للتخفيف حضورهم في الشوارع في محاوله
للضغط على حكومه
من اجل التراجع عن قانون التقاعد على كل
فادي دهوك مراسل العربيه مع الان من باريس
فادي جديد المشهد من عندك ابرز مشاهداتك
وهل تسجل مواجهات عنيفه بين الطرفين
[موسيقى]
اهلا طالب المواجهات متفرقه وهي في عدد
مختلف من زوايا هذه التظاهره الموكب ضخم
جدا كما ترون على الشاشه هناك عشرات
الالاف الذين نزلوا اليوم لاحياء ذكرى عيد
العمال وايضا للاحتجاج على رفع سن التقاعد
الى 64 عاما طبعا حتى الان هناك اربعين
حاله اعتقال بحسب ما اعلنت الشرطه وايضا
هناك اصابات وقعت في صفوف عناصر الشرطه
هناك على الاقل شرطي اصيب بالزجاجه حارقه
الاشتباكات تقريبا تدوم لدقائق ثم يعود
الوضع الى الهدوء كما ترون الان في هذه
النقطه التي نقف فيها طبعا هذا اليوم هو
يوم او هو اهم يوم في السنه بالنسبه
للعمال في فرنسا لانه يوم العمال العالمي
هناك ايضا مشاركه لافته من عدد كبير من
اعضاء النقبات في دول من دول مختلفه هناك
مشاركه من نقابيين من الولايات المتحده من
اسبانيا من ايطاليا
من المانيا ايضا وقبل قليل وثقنا عمليه
اعتقال لشخصين من المانيا قامت الشرطه
باعتقالهما وقالت انهما قام بافتعال الشغب
الشرطه كانت قد حذرت كذلك من وجود عناصر
من شبان اليسار المتطرف المعروفون باسم
الكتله السوداء او البلاك بلوك وهؤلاء
اعدادهم قالت تتراوح ما بين الف الى
سوف يقومون باعمال شغب هم بالفعل قاموا
ببعض الاعمال التي استهدفت بنوكا وشركات
تامين لكن المشهد بشكل عام وهو هادئ نسبيا
والتظاهرات تسير بسلام حتى الان طالب هل
تمت امل يحضر متظاهرين بان الحكومه
ستتراجع عن هذا القانون ام لا ما قد تم قد
تم يعني هذه التظاهرات ستنتهي اليوم يعني
وخلاص
[موسيقى]
فادي هل سمعتني
فادي
يبدو انه فقدنا الاتصال مع فادي على كل
كان يعلق مباشره من العاصمه الفرنسيه
باريس على هذه التظاهرات وهي بعشرات لبل
مئات الالاف كما ذكرت وكالات
الصحافه والاعلام من العاصمه الفرنسيه
في محاوله للاحتجاج على اقرار حكومه رئيس
مكرون قانون التقاعد وبالطبع يعني يستغل
المتظاهرون يوم العمال العالمي في الاول
من مايو لتاجيل هذه التظاهرات فادي انضم
الي مجددا فادي كنت قد سالتك هل تمت امل
يحضو المتظاهرين بان حكومه رئيس ماكرون
ستتراجع تحت ضغط الشارع ام لا يعني
هذه التظاهرات ستنتهي نهايه هذا اليوم
تفضل فادي هذا ما تامله النقابات ادى ما
تامله النقابات من ان ضغط الشارع سوف يجبر
الحكومه على التراجع ولكن حتى الان لا
يوجد اي مؤشر على ان الحكومه مستعده
لتقديم هذا التنازل خصوصا وان المجلس
الدستوري قام بالمصادقه على هذا القانون
وبالتالي وقع الرئيس الفرنسي رسميا عليه
اصبح قانونا قيد التنفيذ لكن هم يعولون
على هذا اليوم لانه يوم مهم جدا
او اختبار لمدى قدره الشارع على الحفاظ
على الزخم وعلى قدره النقبات لاستمرار
التظاهرات كذلك هناك مبادره لطرح استفتاء
والمجلس الدستوري سوف يقوم بدراسه هذا
الطلب في الثالث من هذا الشهر ايضا
النقابات تحاول كل ما في وسعها للصمود
لتجعل الحركه الاحتجاجيه قادره على الصمود
اكثر من خلال جمع التبرعات هائله حتى الان
هناك اربعه ملايين يو رو تم جمعها في احد
صناديق التبرعات هذه التبرعات تذهب في
معظمها الى العمال الذين يقومون
بالاضراب لانهم لان كل يوم اضراب يحسب يوم
اجازه غير مدفوعه الاجر بالنسبه للعمال
الذين يقومون بهذه الاضرابات الطالب فهذه
هل هنالك خطط للتظاهر في الايام المقبله
النقابات سوف تجتمع بعد انتهاء هذه
التظاهره لتقرر عن الخطوات اللاحقه التي
ستتبع هذه التظاهر ولكن ايضا هناك مساله
مهمه وهي ان هناك جهات اخرى تدعو للتظاهر
خصوصا الطلاب هناك تظاهرات تم الدعوه
اليها اليوم مساء في تمام الساعه الثامنه
من مساء اليوم بالتوقيت المحلي لهذه
التظاهره غير مرخصه وهي حراك مستقل تماما
عن حراك النخبات سوف تكون من تنظيم الطلاب
وهي تظاهرات من المتوقع ان تكون عنيفه جدا
على غرار ما حدث خلال الاسابيع الماضيه من
باريس مراسل العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك فادي
على كل هذه المتابعه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات